the Joe Rogan experience well you what
season you guys coming into oh [ __ ]
I don't know seasons it's hard to yeah
just couple years we started on HBO in
2003 but then we used to do but the
first few years they had us do two
seasons they took us took them a while
to get the idea that this is not like
The Sopranos or any other show this kind
of show is a habbit show it has to be on
most of the year we used to do a season
from February to like May and then we'd
be off for four months and come back for
a few months in the fall that's not the
way you can do it when you're following
events a live show so finally somewhere
in there they just okay so then it was
one long season as opposed to two so I
guess they counted the early years is
too
we've been on HBO since 2003 but of
course I started you were on the old
show politically incorrect somebody sent
me a clip of that Wow
I couldn't even bear to watch it just
from the way we looked it was too sad
time is cruel it's actually we look
better now just because we look douchier
younger of course I mean that's the
trade-off and that's is that you're do
sheer when you're younger yeah do look
more pristine shall we say unless beaten
down by time yeah but that started in 93
so I've already passed my we did a 25th
anniversary show about a year and a half
ago yeah in the fall of 18 it aired I
couldn't believe that do you know
they're trying to bring back politically
incorrect who is pay whoever the [ __ ]
they are it came to me Rick ads that's
so funny because I suggested that a
while ago with it not with me hosting it
of course but it was somebody else
hosting it but I don't have to ask my
manager about that I thought we I guess
we sold it I think that's true when we
moved to ABC it must be ABC when we
moved to ABC I think we probably sold
them the rights to the show which is was
probably stupid but at the time it made
sense and well good luck with it
I'm not doing it it was one of those
questions my manager calls me up and
says you're not gonna want to do this
but I'm obligated to tell you why
wouldn't you want it just doesn't seem
like something I'd want to do now I'm
insulted
no I'm just I would never want to take
over your show I know and then I've got
it stripped away they were saying
something though the whole thing was
like you once someone does a show leave
it alone you know right leave it yeah
like if you left and they started doing
real time with Adam Carolla right
you know which is exactly what they will
be doing a new [ __ ] show you know
right do you feel constrained by the
time but the the hour format sometimes I
was on with Howard Stern recently and I
was saying that to him and I feel the
same sometimes when I watch or listen to
you it's it's funny Amir I don't get
America like people's attention span is
either seven seconds or three hours yeah
no there's no in-between
well there's a lot of us that's what it
is this decided April yeah yes exactly
people the shortest attention span see
this is all they have Rizal that's their
that's not true it takes a big risk to
play three hours I mean there are
virtues and vices to both of them I mean
I do like being forced to condense and
for people I always think of the person
watching my show is the person who is
interested in current events but doesn't
have the time to follow it during the
week they've got kids and jobs and lives
they are gonna watch me to catch them up
and it's my job to obviously entertain
them but also to point out what's
important what what happened this week
that you should know about somewhere in
that live hour whether it's in the
monologue or in new rules or the
editorial I do at the end or in the
panel somewhere I want to cover
everything I think you should doesn't
necessarily mean it's the things that
the newspaper or other outlets thought
was important
what I think is really important that's
what I'm going to cover so there is
something to be said for condensing it's
also a lot to be said for letting it
breathe you know I mean letting it
breathe I do miss that sometimes I wish
I could and very often were in the
middle of a discussion and I have to
move on I feel like with way things are
going now with streaming like I know HBO
has their new streaming service maybe
they could just give you an option to
let some some of those conversations
lengthen out it seems like some of them
you're just getting started and you have
to cut them off you're right and again
sometimes people just want the headlines
very often I'm reading something and
it's too long I just think just you
should have given me the New York Times
starts every article not just tell me
what happened yeah don't give me the
background and on a rocky road in
Afghanistan as Fran Lebowitz one said
and just get to the part I care about
right movies are too long
lots of stuff is too long people need
editors but these kind of conversations
lend themselves more than most art forms
to just letting it happen and yeah it's
more natural I mean I like the fact that
unlike my early days when you sweat
backstage and you'd hear The Tonight
Show band playing in some you know
Johnny's gonna ask you this and then
you're gonna say that neither listen
don't [ __ ] veer from this you get in
trouble and this is good I didn't
prepare anything yeah you know obviously
you didn't prepare anything no kidding I
did I really have no list the question
oh no I don't you I like you right I'm
sure I'm not gonna run out of things to
ask you or talk to you about but that's
a talent in itself that you could do
that off the top of your head I think
you think it's not that much of a talent
but trust me a lot of people could not
do that I don't know if I would trust
myself have you said you have two hours
with this guy I I would were I would it
was be in the back of my mind like [ __ ]
what if an hour and 10 minutes in I'm
like [ __ ] I can't they go one more thing
I can't imagine if you and I were
together for two hours we would run out
[ __ ] to talk about it's probably true so
that's this okay it's the same [ __ ]
followed by dead air why complete dead
air
[Applause]